- Naumis is writing in,
"Diverse teams may come
with creative ideas
"alongside when you need quick consensus
"among members with diverse
backgrounds and culture,
"how do we achieve it so that the firm
"moves forward ahead as one team?"
- That's a great question.
Hey Naumis, I've got this...
language is pretty important to me,
I think it's really good.
And the more diversity you have
you tend to find different
cultures coming together.
So I think you need a
common language around,
how do we serve them?
And number one, always use phrases like,
we've got to put ourselves
in the shoes of the customer,
what does the customer need?
Even in meetings I sometimes keep
an empty chair for the customer.
What would the customer want?
What would the customer
want us to do here?
I've always encouraged to have a culture
where you get facts and data in the room.
If anybody's got a point of view
they should say it.
And I think as a leader
you want to encourage
the people who don't speak often,
'cause sometimes they're the
brightest people in the room,
but they might feel intimidated.
And then when you've got that you frame,
what is it we're trying to achieve here?
What is the right answer for the customer?
How do we get to mark?
Or whatever the problem of the day is.
And then you get agreement around
what the decision is.
And then a phrase I use in tur-nil-la is
if you make a decision
and you take no accountability, no action,
and no timeline, and no outcome
of what that decision is
then if you leave the
scene of that decision
then consider that there
was no decision ever made.
Because a decision without an outcome
or an action is hallucination.
It never happens.
So I think a great
culture, a great culture
is where you have the discussion,
you get the facts and the data in,
you put yourself in the
shoes of the customer,
say how do we make a difference here?
You make the decision, you lock that down,
get everybody crystal clear
about what their accountability is
and who's going to be responsible
for delivering that for the team.
And it could be a team effort.
And then you say, right,
what does success look like?
What's the outcome?
When are we going to have it,
30 days, 10 days, five days?
And so let's get back
together the next week,
let's have a coffee and
just make sure we did
what we said we would.
As a leader you can really
be a bit of a hustler,
and also, I think where this is important,
you've got to be authentic
again with yourself.
You've got to hold yourself to account,
so if you commit to things for the team,
you've got to deliver them for you.
And you've got to walk the talk
and set the tone for the
company you're building.
- I like that empty seat for the customer.
I've never heard that.
I've consumed a lot of content,
I've never heard anybody do that,
have an empty seat and
imagine the customer's there.
That's cool, I might use that.
I think two things, I agree with Stephen,
I think the mission is the unifying goal,
like, why are we doing this?
If you have clarity on why you're here,
that makes it so much
easier to gather around
and move forward.
I think too, in terms
of cultural diversity,
a lot of the work can be
done in advance as well.
Ideally, if you're over communicating
and really try to understand each other,
then you already have a sense
of how to work together
before you come to the table
to make this really important decision
and not have to figure
that out on the spot.
If you look at Stephen,
he led off with a quote
from Justin Trudeau, who is
the Canadian Prime Minister,
and every time we do
something, I'm Canadian,
so there's always some
Canadian content in there.
I always appreciate that, right?
Like Stephen's done his homework.
He's always prepared.
I'm sure when he's going to France,
he has some French thing that
he's going to be sharing.
And that means a lot, you know,
to the people that you're talking to,
that you've taken the time to understand
their culture, to understand
them a little bit more,
so that when you do get together
and you have that
important decision to make,
it makes it easier to move
forward in the same paths.
So the alignment around the goal, I know,
so the prep work, the ground work,
the awareness to understand them
prior to having to make that decision,
I think is really important.